[Music]
welcome to your biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link
and i'm rhett this week at the round
table of dim lighting
you could kind of call this a part two
to what we did last week where we talked
about
all the ideas that we've had that have
never seen the light of day
they failed they fizzled out we were
they were rejected
now let me also say that some of the
stuff that we went through last week i
thought about this after the fact
some of those ideas we kind of rejected
like like they didn't even make it to
the first level
of or maybe they were considered by like
an agent or someone who looked at a list
of ideas and said okay this is the one
that i think might be viable
so i didn't want to make give the
impression that every single
idea that we went through last week we
had sat down in a room
with a group of people and pitched it to
them and it was rejected
some of them were they were all rejected
on some level but some just
never like little baby birds that never
even got pushed out of the nest they
just
came out of the egg and then died i
don't like picturing a dead baby bird
because
some don't even get out of the egg
they're in the egg and and they die
inside
that's better and then you just have a
dead bird inside of an egg that's fine
i'm totally right
i'm cool with that but like one of those
that's even grosser to me
no because i eat eggs i crack eggs and i
always have a fear every time
i crack an egg i think to myself is
there going to be a bird in this
that's why you need to shine the light
on it first i don't do that
but the baby birds that are like out and
like
they don't have any feathers and they're
like they're cute they're
they're little dinosaurs their eyeballs
are like huge and like
bruised they look like they there's
bruised all over
you look like you should be talking with
a german accent
i'm going for a different look today i
found this
this sweater but the combination of your
glasses and your sweater i bought this
sweater you look like cashmere by the
way
uh it is peach what was the uh the old
snl skit
sprockets
they wore black man i know you look like
you can't wear them you don't wear pete
the 2021 version of sprocket if rockets
came back it would be peach
i look different but i looked at myself
in the mirror and i was like
i think i look good and then hey i
didn't say you look bad christine
you look german i was fully ready to
come in yeah i've got different glasses
on today
my my signature link glasses
i heard about this broke yeah sorry
about that by the way
and um i punched him i've been wearing
them for
a couple of months broken it's just that
right here
i just noticed one day the lens just
fell out in my hand and it's because
part of the frame it just
broke clear in two now i could super
glue it but
consulting with jenna we're going to
take it to a professional because
and they're going to glue it right
because the
um and you're going to pay him for it i
cannot buy another replica of these
go-to glasses of mine that i've had for
years i'd
like four years ago i did buy a second
pair
and you lost them i got stolen kept them
in my car thanks for spoiling all of my
stories
it's not i mean come on man i just i'm
just that was a punchline continuing the
conversation
it was stolen yeah stolen out of my car
in my own freaking driveway
my second pair of glasses so sorry about
that so that when this
happens you know i should probably get
this i still have my glasses
i i stole those from you so when you
broke your other ones i could give them
to you and i think i've misplaced them
at this point
these are i'm not sticky i'm not
switching to these because i don't like
them enough
but it's a nice change of pace though i
thought you know what it's nice change
of pace for today i'm wearing this peach
sweater you look two
or three iq points smarter than you yeah
exactly
and i was thinking i looked in the
mirror previously hey
i've got it i kind of got a different
look but i think i like it i go
downstairs
and i'm like ready to walk out the door
and christy looks at me and i'm
i'm like yeah she's going to say
she's going to give me a compliment or
at least say i look like that guy from
sprocket she's going to laugh at you
probably
first thing she said was there's like a
red dot on your neck
and you got another one i actually put a
little makeup on it so you can't see it
pull it down again would you what in the
world is it there yeah you got a rash
i don't know what that is maybe it's
from the sweater
you go pull it down again yeah you got a
rash man
i actually feel i think it's just that
i'm flush
i'm kind of wired this morning
anyway i'm to the gym i'm in the market
to some news you went to the gym and you
got your heart rate up
that's what it is yeah maybe yeah i'm in
the market for some new glasses but i'm
gonna get
as close to my go-to glasses as i can
get because
going this far away i never wear them
because they're i don't i don't
they're too far well too far from the
real me and speaking of
being too far we went kind of far afield
there what i was getting to
was uh what we're going to talk about
today is
how we've dealt with that rejection you
know more on an emotional
level and what that has done to us uh
years and years of having things you
know rejected
multiple things that we can never bring
to the light of day or things that were
brought to the light of day that
then i mean are considered failures like
how do you
how do you move on after failure from a
creative standpoint
yeah so we'll discuss that i do want to
give you an update
on uh one of my children
uh choose one i'll pick the older one
and
so i think we've we've covered the fact
that our kids got a little bit later
start with the whole
getting their driver's license thing
it's a generational thing kids are not
rushing on their 16th birthday to get
their license at least not in los
angeles i guess because of
uber um and and then covid
of course had a pretty large impact on
everybody's
plans yeah like for locke it was he
needed to get his driving lessons
and then once kovit hit it was like well
you can't we don't really want you to
get into the car with somebody right now
so
but anyway since we're coming out on the
on the other side of that
he has he's got his permit and so
he can drive us around now jesse
even though he is now he's already seven
he's already 17. he could have he could
have had his license
long ago 15 and a half he could have
right he could have taken his drive
what he's doing now and and every day he
tells me how much he regrets
not going with the original schedule and
i say this is why i told you 100 times
at least that you should do this you say
i know i just sometimes i just have to
learn things the hard way dad damn
that's a milestone man
i mean that right there is what every
parent lives for
the when you say i told you so and
they're like you're right
how often does that happen well often in
my house no no actually no god
it doesn't no it's interesting because
it is happening more lately with him
like i thought that someone i thought
that there would be things that would be
like okay you know
when he's is it a pill that i can get my
kids when he's like
28 he'll he'll come home for christmas
and he'll be like you know what
you guys were actually pretty good
parents you know yeah
uh but he actually i i told you this
yesterday he he recently said
i've actually realized recently that you
guys are actually pretty good parents
it's like and you just gotta understand
did you get suspicious we're like what
are you
coming no he wasn't asking for anything
he was just experiencing some things
with
uh you know other parents and stuff and
and has points of reference and stuff
and he's you know
appreciating his own parents so oh us
you talking about
the meals
no uh so anyway so he is driving
now and jessie had this stipulation
she was like i'm not driving with him
you can drive with him
her and lock tend to
kind of get into it sometimes and i
could only ima
and she could only imagine what it would
be like if she's trying to
you know the classic trope of the the
the new driver and the parent in the
passenger seat it's funny
losing their mind it's funny because
christy said the same thing about jessie
said what that she she wasn't gonna
drive
yeah well can you imagine jesse's
offspring but it's also my offspring so
i was like okay i mean
then that means that we're just going to
be driving on the weekends because
that's like the time that i've got in
order to do this and so
the first couple of like driving lessons
were going to
a big parking lot and getting the basics
of the car down like
okay this is you know literally like
you know when we grew up we had we had
driven like golf carts and
go-karts and four-wheelers we had a lot
of driving experience
my kid's a city kid it's just he's come
up different and so there wasn't like
all this
driving experience that you could just
transfer over to a car so it's a little
bit like
oh the gas is here and the break is here
like it was we were literally at that
point and i
i'm i'm just i'm basically just getting
through that point with
lincoln who is uh you know he just
turned 16.
and it's you take him to a parking lot
and for the reason you're talking about
there's like it's not a big parking lot
that you can
like find that's empty there's people
there's at least four there's four other
cars just like parked they're lurching
slowly
yeah and so that's actually seems worse
because it's like all these cars are
just gonna lurch into each other because
they don't know that there's any gas in
the break
and you know it's this is actually a
great time uh
i mean it's the traffic is picking up
but i would say that a couple months ago
when
we started doing these little adventures
la traffic is as low as it's ever been
in
in the history of our 10 years of being
here but probably in the past
30 40 years because of because of covid
so
but if you want to experience going back
you can watch the latest tarantino movie
it has a lot of la driving that's
basically all i remember about the movie
which which
one that and brad pitt on lsd but oh uh
the holy spirit upon a time in hollywood
um so anyway so yes we did the parking
lot thing and i wasn't
too confident i was like i wanted him to
get
the feel of like okay this is how you
pull
up into a parking space this is how you
you back
out and this is how you you put the
brakes on you shift the gears and
you you're getting those the
transitional points of driving which is
a really big
part of driving yeah yeah just being on
a road and going straight and stopping
and then starting again
that's not driving that ain't driving
yeah i remember telling i was telling
lincoln i was like
i was he was in the driver's seat and i
realized i needed to tell him how to
what to do with his hands in order to
turn a 90 degree turn
and i'm like same thing well you're
supposed to you're supposed to grab and
i told him what to do
based on what i thought i would do and
then i was like i was like you know what
pull
over i don't think i think what i'm
telling you is not what i do
and i was totally right it's like you
think you should you're supposed to like
grab
hand over hand and then when i did it i
was like doing something totally
different
right now i just want to get a timeline
straight here
with your story with lock because you
have told the story of when we went to
death valley you let him drive
in the desert which which was like a
series of well that was the first time
he that was the first time he ever drove
and it was a little bit traumatic right
so and i was a little bit worried like
is he gonna be okay
well when we got back from from from
death valley
and you know he actually he didn't have
his permit at that time i don't think
and lincoln still doesn't that's why
we're only in a parking lot but
if so but now he has it and so we're
able to like legally
let him drive not just in the middle of
the desert so
he he did the parking lot thing and
there was a couple of times where
i i was you know sometimes you you find
yourself
becoming the stereotypical dad
who's like yelling and saying things
that you're gonna regret yeah and you
kind of catch yourself you're like i
feel like i'm on a sitcom right now like
i'm murray goldberg or whatever you know
and um some grunting the occasional fart
but he was doing pretty good and so then
i was like all right well let's take
this out into the
neighborhood so we kind of drove around
some
like quiet neighborhood streets yep and
then i realized that so he was coming to
stops
abruptly like we would stop and he would
be going a little bit too fast and he
would stop and then even he was going a
little bit too slow when he would come
to a stop and roll through a stop there
would be like a
a jerk that moment where the breaks
totally seized
totally seized and then when he takes
off he would go
and then i i found myself your brain
hitting the back of your skull
every time i found myself becoming my
dad you know my dad
my dad didn't just tell you how to do
things
he like there was like a second level of
like style that he thought was important
it was
philosophical so i was like look listen
i'm gonna tell you as i teach you to
drive
i'm going to tell you a lot of things
that are going to make you a better than
average driver
that's your goal is to be better than
average right and i was like there's a
lot of people
who are never going to learn some of the
uh
intricacies that i'm going to teach you
yes and then one of the things that i'm
going to teach you is the smooth
yes to be smooth there's three ways that
you can be smooth in a car
okay the first way is stopping the
second way
is going and the third way
the third oh man oh whoa hold on i'm on
i'm on the edge of my seat now because
you already did you already covered
stopping and going
and there's a third one the third one is
but we'll get to the third one right
after this
nope psych here it is while you're
driving now you know this because we
talked about it a million times you get
into a car with like an uber driver yeah
yeah
and there are there are many uber
drivers and drivers in general
who do this like pulsating
acceleration thing where they're like
it's like instead of just like
treating you need to treat the gas pedal
and the brake
like i don't want to get sexual here but
go go for it it's like foreplay you know
what i'm saying is this what you told
like
i was like you got i didn't use the i
didn't use foreplay as an analogy i
thought that would be inappropriate but
i'm using it here that's a fun i mean
talk about a
fun driving lesson you you want your
foot to be
on that brake and you want it to ease
and then i was like and there's the art
of the
of the roll right when you sense that
the brakes are about to lock up
you really release a little bit and this
is of course to carry the foreplay thing
right when you're about to uh you pull
back
okay and so and then when you take off
you want to
go you don't want to go straight pedal
to the metal you want to eat and i said
picture it i didn't know this is what he
was going to talk about when i said hey
you should sit in on this one because
we're fully vast um
i said picture it as if you had a glass
of wine and i don't know why oh this
i chose glass of wine again i said
you've got a glass of wine on the
dashboard
and you want that to stay perched
on the dashboard that's how smooth you
need to be at all times
because you're creating an experience
for the other passengers in your
in your car and then every time you come
to a smooth stop you want to take a deep
gulp of that wine
and so what and uh and then i said
something like
i i actually at one point i switched it
to
i said a glass of water he said you just
said you said a glass of wine a second
ago
he's like totally on board man and like
you know what he's getting it so
we've been driving together and like he
the thing is is that lock's mind works a
lot like mine and so instead of thinking
that what i was saying was ridiculous
he understood that there was a standard
that we could hold ourselves to
when driving that was above just getting
around safely
that's profound getting around with
style is
what you're aspiring to now if you want
to if you as the
tutor or the professor of driving school
if you want to go full miyagi on this
thing
you need to bring a glass of wine yeah i
i thought about this
that's that's the ultimate test this
this is not he's got he's got his
driving test in a couple
of weeks and i'm going to tell him to
take a class take a glance
it's like my dad told me to bring me
that's good man let's
i mean it's so funny because that's one
of the first things that i was
teaching lily and that uh
i've started to instill in lincoln is
this same principle of like
as you're stopping you got to picture
the break
about the grip it's like i tried to
explain how the break works
you become the anti-light brakes right
so that as
it as it closes down as the brake pad
closes down
on it then at the last second you want
to release it a little bit
right exactly but i didn't use the i i
was very practical
and i i think i missed the mark with an
inspirational analogy yeah
i don't think you have to go for play i
think the glass of wine kind of covers
everything
you put the glass of wine on the
dashboard
you want it to stay filled you don't
want it to spill when you're stopping
starting or any time while going taking
a taking a turn
all about smoothness yeah you you want
to be stopped before you realize it
you that's just a surprise oh we we're
we're stopped and let me tell you right
we're going again let me tell you in the
same way
that many people go their entire lives
without dealing with their own halitosis
which is a
there's a certain percentage of the
population that doesn't ever deal with
the halitosis right
there's a certain percentage of the
population that never ascends
to the smooth driving level this is our
new this is
this is the second this is our second
mission in life yeah
first mission is to get people to deal
with their nasty stink ass breath well i
was in a second
to get them to be smooth drivers and
let's just take the opportunity
gargle with 50 hydrogen peroxide
50 water or mix it with wine if you're
feeling
if you're feeling freaky you can put a
glass of hydrogen peroxide on your
dashboard
and do both at the same time oh yes
there it is
hey we just figured it out we need to
start the rent like driving school man
it's like when you leave here your
breath will smell like a
i was gonna say a baby's
anyway lock's doing great uh his drive
his driving instructor told him now this
is after a few lessons with dad
okay the the mr miyagi of driving as
link is just
i did not say that you fell short of
that the driving instructor
said you know what you're a natural
and he said i gotta tell you a lot of
these kids that i teach are just
dumbasses that's what he said and he was
like but you're but you're a natural in
fact he says you could pass your test
right now and he drove on the highway
and then just the other day
for a mother's day brunch um
jessie and i i mean uh we the boys and i
drove to meet jesse at uh
she was getting some time alone uh for
mother's day in a hotel and we met her
for a brunch in
in west hollywood so we were like this
is like a 40-minute drive
and he drove he had the full la driving
experience driving
on the 101 driving over the canyon
laurel canyon like i was like
and then driving in you know west
hollywood and the traffic wasn't that
bad on a sunday but i was like
hey man you know this is if you can
drive here you can drive anywhere in the
united states
north carolina would be a breeze at this
point for you so
i think he's he's he's uh he's getting
there see christy was in the car
we also went to west hollywood for for
mother's day just the place to be but
christy was in the car so
i did not it didn't even cross my mind
to suggest
that lily drive the car oh chris
christie will get a little anxious about
it yeah oh well and lily will also get
anxious
you know if like this is our big you
know we got to make it to the
brunch i only yelled very loudly
one time what what did you yell it may
have been a curse word
i think it was like that kind of thing
you know uh
but i think it was uh he was doing great
but then
uh there was a car that was stopped in
the middle uh like a car that had broken
down in the middle of the 101
and he got right up behind it and had to
like pull he pulled in front of somebody
but then he moved over one more lane and
like really cut somebody off and
uh i yelled at that point when we but
then i immediately let me say i
immediately apologized
okay okay i was like hey i'm sorry about
yelling because because he ever
crisis averted and he was like dad i'm
calm
ooh ooh and i was like you know what
that's good i had to hurt
master becomes the t uh student yeah
well i mean daniel did win his match at
the end of
i wasn't a credit kid when we
you know to harken back to when we did
the college visit
that was a long drive and i got chris i
i got lily to drive some of the way even
though she did not want to
you got to get them on the freeway you
got to get them emerging you got to get
emerging that's what they're all scared
of well
i've done that like we did the whole
well let's go out and let's mer
let's take every off-ramp and on-ramp oh
every off-ramp and
that's called the miyagi merge yeah we
did that because that's on and off yep i
only wish there was one
merge on merge
is the guy who played him dead does that
mean we have the rights yes
is that is that how they worked
illegally uh pat marita
pat maria how do i know his name i don't
know but i
i you know what if you had given me like
seven hours i could have arrived
wow i mean i have really impressed you
you haven't you still haven't even seen
the original karate kid
not all of it i feel like i have rita uh
i watched the pilot
of the uh i don't want to get off on
that so i got lily to drive
and we're on the freeway and then we're
like going we're going through some
hills
off the freeway okay and um she's doing
good but it was a little scary
first time it's the first time we were
all in the car and she was driving
and i wanted to i wanted to get an idea
of like how was landon
longer distance driving well was he more
was he
scared her than christy at one point he
said um
i don't feel good and then he said i
don't feel good
a few minutes later he's like i don't
feel good
you know how the i don't feel good gets
shorter and shorter more staccato
eventually it turns into i feel bad
and then you transition it turned into
christie's like i think we need to pull
over
and then i'm like we got to find a good
spot and lily i don't want you to panic
but
you know we were going like 70 miles per
hour on it's like kind of curvy roads
four lanes it was challenging
and i wanted to i was like okay i see a
spot you're going to pull over up there
lando we're pulling over up there uh
we hit the gravel and then the vomit
from the very back of the car hits
christy's seat
in the middle of the car he threw up on
her as we were stopping and pulling out
you talk about dad yelling i'm like
just hold it in your mouth oh that's
what he meant just hold it in your mouth
i didn't realize he was getting sick i
thought he was up he felt
unsafe no he felt nauseous
and he vomited in the in the car and
that's where the smoothness comes in
because then he got out
you make your passenger sick if you
don't take those and sometimes the roads
are you can't avoid it and when you're
in the very back
like the way back it's even worse and
you're and you're a kneel
and that's what we get cars and that's
what we teach at the miyagi school of
driving and fresh breath
christy christie was trying so christy
hopped out
it was like there was a fire inside of
the car it's like if you were watching
from across the street at the fruit
stand
where the guys were watching we pull
over the
all the doors open we're trying to get
lando out christy gets out of
her seat in the middle of the the suv
and she
she yanks up on the thing to make the
seat the fly the object button
yeah to make the seat fly forward so
that lando can crawl out from behind the
seat
and as she's doing that he's vomiting on
the seat and she's vomiting again
she i think that was the first vomit
like as we stop
she hops out okay he's vomiting on the
seat
he's gonna kill me for telling this
story but he's not gonna listen no one's
gonna tell him
right don't send it don't add him on
twitter um
christy's panicking so much because i'm
yelling for him to hold it in your mouth
yeah like a good dad he she we don't
accept that at the
miyagi school she cannot vomit in a car
you are expelled
she ripped the handle that makes the
seat go forward she rips it off it's in
her hand
and then lock i mean uh lando has to
crawl across the seat and get out and
vomit some more on the side of the
road and i still don't know how to fix
it how did you
how did you clean it up did you have
vomit smell the rest of the rice uh
we had wipes the neo's got wipes man
yeah but the white coffee the
mclaughlins would be in trouble we'd
have like
one napkin for mcdonald's so in the
glove compartment we blame that on lily
and then i i took
over from there but i think it was the
windows down i think it would have been
me
it would have happened if i was driving
anyway it's what i'm trying to say right
it was the road
well anyway the kids are doing great
that was let's enough of their successes
let's get to our failures
but first uh let's talk about the
wonderful collection of grooming
items that we have that all fit nicely
into a mythical
green bag we care about what we look
like
i mean can you tell i mean just look at
me today
i mean i look like i'm told i look
amazing
by friends by by my wife
uh by strangers um
we developed everything in this sack to
make you look
as good as we think we look can you use
the term bag
we got a mythical brush this is this is
uh
it's like a wet dry brush is this jenna
approved
yeah it is that's great that's great
it's great working on my hair works on
jenna's hair
jenna has so much more hair than we do
mythical hand lotion
subtly scented but soothing i don't use
that i got to be honest with you i'm not
a lotion guy but i think boys
he's got i love it covered in it i love
the scent
of it the mythical number nine when
you're teaching driving sometimes
putting lotion on your hands
makes it slippery on the wheel so clay
pomade it's what i use in my hair we
don't do that in miyagi school
uh that right there i love the smell of
that too
smell of that we got a musical calm i
mean this thing
as we've already established is
incredible uh
that's fun uh we got some beard balm
the pomade's not in here but you get the
idea we got the beard oil
and we've got the peculiar you perfect
peanut butter peppermint lip balm
and the candy milk lip balm get yours
today
at mythical.com i got to put this stuff
away
stahl rhett say something oh you know
what i can tell you about i can remind
you that the first two
episodes of the scripted podcast that
we're starring in called
ron stat drop to morrow
again this is a scripted podcast this is
a totally immersive world
it's about a dude named ron statt who is
a 9-1-1
phone jockey who answers all the weird
sort of supernatural calls
he has a special ability that gives him
uh
the the ability to maybe make some to
exercise some decisions based on the
cause that he gets
and you know all about ronstep because
you embodied the role
of ron staff in this uh
and a lot of you have been asking as
like the trailer and stuff has come out
and now
the episodes like what was what was your
inspiration in creating this
like well we didn't create ron stat we
just
you know we want to be clear about that
it was uh
it was q code brought the opportunity to
us and we got to know johnny and brando
who created it
and they wrote the entire first season
so we had the benefit of being able to
to read um the plot and the world that
they've created
and it really resonated with us there
were a lot of like
mythical-esque elements and just
just the world and the tone and the fact
it was exciting for us to get involved
um so we'd love to say that we created
it but
we didn't we we were brought on to the
project later and
um brought on as producers uh as well
and so that kind of helps answer some of
the questions that people have had it's
just like well
usually when you guys do something like
it's about two dudes because you're two
dudes and this is not really like that
like
rhett's playing ron's dad and link's
playing like like three other roles
yeah it was yeah and there was a moment
that's like okay
is this for us but i think um you know
because we were really excited about the
project
and doing something that was getting our
feet wet in this
in in a different genre scripted audio
podcast like you get back into that
radio teleplay type stuff
all of that's coming back around and
if and maybe we'll create something from
the ground up later
yeah but to get involved in that project
like we first heard about it in january
i mean if
if you were a part of the mythical
society ama you already know this
but right the pacing with which we were
able to just jump in and get involved
kind of made it it made it a no-brainer
um
and it also gave me the opportunity to
say uh
you know what i can play a couple of
different roles here
and see where i fit in so you'll see
where i fit in as the season unfolds
you just wait so super immersive world
and the fact that all this can happen
just between your ears and it's your as
big as your imagination wants to make it
it's just something that it's a medium
we're excited to be involved with
ronstat first two episodes drop tomorrow
wherever podcasts are found okay before
we get into
creative failure um and rejection
i just wanted to start off with like
some relational rejection
have you ever read uh been relationally
rejected
of course not i know you
i know you would you'd set your sights
on
a girl but that didn't necessarily mean
that their sights were set on you
you know i actually i thought about this
recently um
i actually had a tendency well i think
there's two things going on
first of all i just really like women
and and that started very early
and i and it was very intense like from
well i'm not talking this was like not
at puberty this is before puberty
this is like first grade right i just
had i had
infatuation issues and and i would kind
of get focused on
a girl and typically
uh i would focus on someone who
you dream about flying to her house well
i would focus on
girls that were for lack of a better
word unattainable
for me right like i don't know what it
was it would be like okay this girl is
two years
older than me uh and it would be
embarrassing for her to date me even if
we were in the same
grade she probably wouldn't date me
right i mean you've seen pictures of me
growing up
uh and so i was a little bit gangly but
i had a lot of confidence
and i would uh and once i kind of made
that decision
i would begin what i guess
was my version of flirting and talking
and telling
other people that i like this girl
telling their friends that i like them
moving and shaking trying to get
something going and there are a couple
of times where this was a successful
strategy and that was all i needed to
continue doing it
but i would say that just a percentage
breakdown
that's probably 80 20 80 rejection 20
success um so rejected more often than
i was accepted so it oh i
i didn't think it was that much of a
spread sorry
so does that mean that not no one
rejection stands out
uh
well i mean i might i if you're talking
about my like my biggest crush
in high school i don't even consider
that a rejection because it was so
unrealistic
but like there i remember a girl but
like do you
like one where you were like to her face
saying will you
be my girlfriend or how will you go with
me or what
will you go out on a date and she was
like ah i know
i don't think well you know how it was
in like middle school high school it
never
never really got to the point where you
were face to face
asking and being rejected the rejection
usually
came through a friend before you got
there
that helps right uh yeah and i i mean
the funny thing is is i don't ever
remember
again it's hard to remember exactly
emotionally what
was going on in high school
but i would kind of just be like okay
all right
um that's not happening
so i would just kind of move on so you
never like
you never shook you that you can recall
no hmm okay because for me
i mean my problem was was the opposite
like i never got
i was so anxious and self-aware and just
kind of felt like i didn't know what i
i didn't know what i wanted and it was
so much about
what should i be doing so that i can
you know fit in or whatever so like
girls would i would hear through the
grapevine that some girl wanted to date
me and then i was like
oh crap this is a huge test i feel like
i'm gonna fail there was a lot of fear
and anxiety that short-circuited it was
just like the polar opposite of you
at that time you know it short-circuited
so many of these experiences so for me
to say well you know what i don't think
i was ever rejected
is definitely not a brag at all because
and i think this is something that when
we talk about
the creative ramifications of uh
rejection and failure
it's that it's this dynamic of fear kind
of keeping you from
action and if you overcome that
to whether that's to create or initiate
with somebody or try to initiate some
sort of a relationship
it's um
you never know what can happen if you if
you go for it
but you know what's going to happen if
you don't nothing right
and and i i think for me the only
rejection was
i mean definitely i was dumped by janna
yeah my sophomore year she was a
freshman and in my
she wrote me a note in my and i put it
in my
she wrote me the note that we were
breaking up because i was just a friend
to her because i was
i clammed up so much around her and i
was so
anxious in my and in my own head and it
was about what should i be doing and not
how do what what do i want to do i was
so
i was so in my own head and she was very
nice and she let me off the hook but it
was a
i mean i remember reading that letter
and
boy that was it was embarrassing to be
like okay i just consider
you're a great person in europe i read
the letter
on good mythical morning because once we
moved to la i found myself
i brought my soccer bag out here for
some reason i got a keeper soccer ball i
thought i was gonna play some soccer
after not playing for like a decade or
something it was sentimental value to
have my cleats and stuff in there and
but i found that i had kept that
rejection letter
i guess i don't know why i did it i'd
like to think it was some sort of
lesson that then i was gonna be i was
gonna go after what i wanted from then
forward and i wasn't gonna
i wasn't gonna let fear clam me up
but i don't think that was actually the
case yeah i just think it was like
man this is this hurts i'm
but it's i'm i'm so sentimental i'm
gonna i'm gonna shove it in this bag
and i'm never maybe i didn't go in that
pocket anymore or maybe i wouldn't use
it
i was giving you good advice at the time
man i was like this is quite an
opportunity that you're being been given
like
because she like invited you to her
house i went to her house and i was like
well you should definitely accept that
invitation
yeah one of my biggest regrets is not
riding the four-wheeler with her right
yeah and that's not a euphemism that's
literally
riding a four-wheeler we were in north
carolina but that i mean
that would have been so awesome i mean
here i am
you know about to turn 43 years old
and i'm still regretting not not not
straddling her on that four-wheeler
right yeah i mean we both be facing the
same
i don't know we ca who knows what
directions we would have been facing
there's lots of things we could have
been faces
every direction the seat is very wide i
mean
i mean once i got away from there's
probably a whole
like section on some porn website of
just stuff that happens on atvs
i'm not saying i know about it i'm just
saying that that's how specialized
things can get
now you got to wield the power that we
have with caution because just saying
that
is going to like spike that surge what
if it generates a whole new
category of porn i mean we can take
credit for that too the miyagi
school of driving fresh breath and atv
porn
okay so we're teaching people how to
have sex on an atv
there's a bunch of atvs there those are
driving no that's just for sex
oh man okay that rejection that
rejection hurt so i guess
i mean that's all we have to go into the
relational stuff
but just to get just to get back to the
creative stuff
let's get in our minds what we feel like
is not rejection but failure what's our
like biggest creative failure
do you have something in your mind i
have something in my mind i mean the
first thing that comes to mind
is gmo 22. yeah that that's that's my
answer and we've
i mean we devoted a whole episode at the
it would be interesting to go back and
listen to that oh i'm not going to go
back and i don't
i don't want to do that you can do that
because that was like that was one of my
i am not proud of i'm i'm not but we can
talk about that because i think that's a
that's a good example of
the way that failure and rejection can
kind of get into your head
because i got i got very well just a
little background
categorize what it was so uh
what year was that 2017
i don't know 2018 2018 17 and 18
17 18. okay so we were given the
opportunity
we were approached by youtube they were
investing in different kinds of content
they actually
originally came to us i don't know if
we've ever talked about this part of it
but they originally came to us and
asked us if we would make like a a a
late show version of good mythical
morning so like a good mythical night or
something like that
and um we were like that sounds like a
great idea but
like we're already kind of really
doing all we can with good mythical
morning and we're like is there some way
to expand good mythical morning itself
which going back in time it kind of
feels like we should have just done the
late show version but anyway in addition
to gmm because we ended up doing
five parts of a show every single day i
think it went down to four but anyway it
was like a multi-part
thing and the the technology worked
against us but also
you know it's we said yes we took we
wanted to go for it
and it did not work i mean long story
short it didn't work and it
it hurts when it is you know if you
create something and you put your heart
and soul into it
i'm saying this by contrast i'm not
describing what we did with that but
if in a as as an artist if you create
something that you pour your heart and
soul into and then nobody sees it
or cares about it that's a certain type
of failure it's a different thing
what we experienced was something that
was near and dear to
so many mythical beasts um that they
cared about so much
and we messed with it in a way that
frustrated
them and was not a good experience which
then made it a
in an even more difficult experience for
us because we were
we were trying to take into account the
all of the fee there was so much
feedback yeah um
so that was a certain type of very
scrutinized
failure it's kind of like the like the
water world like big
budget movie scenario where everybody's
geared up to see it
and then it's just horrible so it
becomes the
you know the the object lesson of
cinema no nose you know it's like maybe
i
and because there was the digital space
is
much more experimental and
frontier-like it it i don't think it
serves
and no one's emulating gmm to the point
where it becomes a cautionary tale
um so i don't know exactly what we
learned but i think well i'm sure we
learned a lot as well
and and we both agree uh that
we're we're very glad that we said yes
and we tried it i mean because
there are a number of things that came
from that um
it trans honestly it transformed our
business right we ended up right moving
into
the space next door which uh and we
ended up
more than doubling our staff the funding
that we had we put to work
in ways that we're still seeing those
benefits now
we were able to take so many of the
things that we learned just from a
creative and a production standpoint
and then incorporate it back into gmm
when we went back to the one
episode a day version so so i take i
totally take back what i said just like
i don't know if we learned anything
no because i think the point the
principle is absolutely we learned
a whole bunch of stuff and that's kind
of the point and it
and it kind of redeems the experience
right if it
if that didn't work but it changed the
trajectory
of of where we're headed and
i can't even articulate all the lessons
that we
learned but they're ingrained in our
experience and
impact the decisions that we have been
making ever since then
and i think that's that's a principle of
of failure is it's less of a failure
if you went for something tried
something and learned from it
then not going for anything and learning
nothing
and you might have saved face a little
bit
but i mean if it would have destroyed
good mythical morning and it wouldn't
have recovered
then it would be maybe that could have
happened differently businesses go
bankrupt people try things they have bad
ideas well they have good ideas that
just things out of their control
tank it you know that absolutely could
have happened for us
um and then it it would have been a
regret and it would have been what we
call a mistake
but but even the creative failure i i
choose to believe that even then
it would have led to something else
because that's that's just
my experience is that is always there's
a lesson
thankfully the lesson didn't come along
with a complete
you know fumbling of good mythical
mourning and killing it it came back
but there's always a lesson and you know
and i'm especially grateful for it
because that's why i started going to
therapy you know
and because of just how difficult that
time was not just the rejection it was
it was more the rejection was difficult
but it was more just it was too it was
too much to take on
but you know the reason i don't want to
go back and listen to that
uh episode um
where we like essentially complained and
defended ours
and i me i did it more than you did so i
i take credit for that i was defensive
i was i was in a bad place i was hurt i
was trying to
i said some things i regret now
i think that my if this were if that
were to happen today
post therapy my processing of what was
going on would be very different
because one of the things and is it next
week that we're going to start talking
about
the enneagram yes okay gonna do it so we
are gonna
start so stay tuned next week and maybe
even the following week we may do a
two-part thing with the enneagram where
we're going to talk about what the
enneagram is a little bit but more just
talk about our experience with it what
numbers we are and how that
has impacted our lives but
i am uh enneagram 3 i'm a performer
there's a number of things that might go
into that meaning that
there's it's part nature part nurture
that i'm a ve i have been a very
performance-minded person
and when you're a person who finds their
worth in
their success
you might also be a person who finds
their worthlessness
in their failure and so
i think that there is a again and i have
been
you know things have gone really well
for me you know what i'm saying things
have gone really well for us things have
also gone well for me individually
before we ever
started doing what we did it was just
like i kind of prided myself on being
good at stuff right it's like okay i'm
going to
make good grades i'm going to be good at
basketball i mean
the things that i choose to do i'm going
to do them well right
and so i kind of developed
this sense of self that was based on
being good at things and then when it
keeps happening
when you keep trying and of course
there's lots of failures there's
rejections like those relational
i wouldn't say that dating was one of
the things i was good at
so i just put that out there i did
really well
one time with my wife and and and and
things have worked out really well since
then
um but this this idea
i think the thing that was so difficult
about gmm 22 because it was
because it was such a public
failure in terms so many people saw as
you guys tried something and it did not
work
and it's so obvious to everybody why
don't you just admit
now isn't that embarrassing yeah and
again
there's this you start if you're me you
start
you've placed some of your own personal
value
in the way that what you've created is
received
right and so i told you last week my my
recommendation was elizabeth gilbert's
big magic which i was talking to my
therapist about that and he was like oh
you know i used to recommend
to a lot of people her ted talk which if
you don't want to read the book
which i do recommend the book you can
kind of get a lot of the same ideas and
she's done
she's actually done a number of really
popular ted talks where she talks she
talks about this
but she kind of emphasizes this this
idea of
what you create uh matters a whole lot
but also doesn't matter at all
right there's this sort of built-in
irony like
it's it's sacred and it's awesome and
the creative
creative expression is is an incredible
thing but also
you kind of have to live as if
it doesn't matter especially
how it's received the thing that you
can't control the thing you can control
is what you create and how you create it
the thing you cannot control
is this reception and we operate in this
world where reception
is such a big piece of the pie
yeah because we throw things out there
constantly we're throwing things out
there to this
the most interactive media genre that's
ever
existed you know what has happened with
since youtube right
so immediate feedback and also this
high quantity of content that's going
out there so you're just getting this
constant feedback that's shaping
everything
and so that's been very difficult for me
a performance based person
to create in a medium where approval
literally like how many people like this
how many people watch it there's
it is approval is quantifiable and it's
a reflection
in your mind of what people think of you
their assessment
of you as a person oh you must not be as
smart as i thought you were a rent link
because
you made a decision that led to
something that was embarrassing
right that was a failure you know i
think the thing for us though
is because we have this long-standing
and growing relationship with our
audience
that it it's it created a soft place for
us to fall
you know where um if
i i think any anybody who listens to
this podcast
uh weekly has a sense of
who we are and is is on board
we have a you know it's there's an
understanding
and there's a there's a belief in hey i
might
i like these guys you know i'm i'm loyal
to these
guys if you stick around even if some
things that they create
are not don't aren't the best thing for
me
like you may have a favorite artist who
has a body of work that from album to
album you may not like every single
album
the same like sturgeon simpson like i
feel like
i have a relationship with his work not
with him
that is you know is it's special to me
but there's certain albums that like i
really applaud the fact that he's doing
his thing
and it's it wasn't for me and and
there's been a few of those albums right
and
but i'm but i still i still believe in
him and like
it give him this and those weren't
failures they just weren't for me but
even if they were failures i'm like
hey you know i'm i'm still a fan and i
respect the fact that like just because
i don't like it or
even if people didn't like it that he
was doing his thing
and i'm on board for that and we have we
have the
the benefit of having that soft place to
fall because
we have that that loyalty and that
relationship built
there's you know i was reading quest
love's creativity book which spoiler
alert i'll i'll recommend at the end and
give you details about it
but he's talking about he talked about a
creative failure
and if people don't and the type of
failure that like if you put something
out into a world and nobody notices or
cares
and he's he was spinning that in a
positive way as
there's freedom in that there's freedom
in that to do something there's freedom
that we don't have
because everything we do because of our
success has a level of scrutiny
um that if if you're
a developing artist and you do something
that doesn't
work you can you can focus on the
freedom to then try something new
and and not be under the thumb of
people's expectations i think there's a
there's a way to redeem
every failure or every rejection
and i definitely think that's
finding there's always you can always
see it as an opportunity if you want to
you can always spin and focus on the
positive
and you can learn things from it you
know if it if it
if it builds into who you are and
changes who you are
and absolute then it was worth it right
and it it enables you to move forward as
long as you don't
as long as you don't allow it to keep
you from moving forward and
i definitely feel that if
we yeah as we talk about gmm 22 now
and if we continue to talk about it
we're not
because i'm just not that interested in
it but like i'm interested in talking
about the other
some other failures and rejections our
conversation would continue to be
different
like so all the stuff that you said and
that
i would say if we were continuing to
talk about it would be different than
what we're saying at that point in time
when we were still really reeling from
it
you know and i'm and i th that may be
the biggest takeaway
that there's a that the experience made
us
um maybe maturity is the right word or
um well we had the you know
we have the benefit of
being able to kind of get back on the
horse and throw something else out into
the world it's kind of what you're
saying a soft place to land you've got
an audience
you it's not like you when we made a
television show that got one season
which we can
we you know our two tv things both our
very first foray in 2007
as hosts that show was short-lived
and then the show that you know we
actually helped make and create there
was much more about
us got one season commercial kings and
uh and then it's like you can't just
turn around and churn out another
television show but you can
turn to the internet and turn to a
faithful audience so we do have this
ability to kind of we have this distinct
advantage
of not having to sort of sit in
our failure and not be able to move
forward creatively and one of the things
that
uh elizabeth gilbert talks about and i
think this may be in the book but it's
definitely one of the ted talks but
she talks about how uh you know
she had the incredible success of
writing uh eat pray love which got
turned into a movie i haven't read the
book or seen the movie no
i don't necessarily plan to i'm not sure
it's for me but it was a huge success it
was on
the bestseller list for like three years
you know and then she experienced this
incredible success and then there was
all this pressure on
writing her next book and she wrote her
next book and it bombed
and she was like thank goodness i got
that out of the way it's like
unlike harper lee who she talks about in
big magic who wrote the kill of
mockingbird and then didn't write
anything else
and she didn't write anything else
because she was scared of
not being able to repeat the success of
to kill a mockingbird
now i thought there was a hidden novel
no she did that something else was
released later but i'm saying for a long
time
but yeah but it wasn't harper lee did
not
publish it i think she was so scared so
one of the things that she talks about
is how
you've got this home position right and
then success
throws you away from home
and failure throws you away from home
but emotionally
you don't really have the cognitive
ability to
feel the difference in other words
success can be just as disorienting as
failure can right um and
and also it goes to your head in a
similar way right
so you can success can breed fear
failure can breed fear and she's like
whether you
are super successful with something or
something is a huge flop
the goal for her is to return home is to
return to home base
and for her home is doing the thing
that she would do anyway if success or
failure
you know whether people are watching or
not and that's writing for her right
uh it's simple for her she's going to go
back to writing and that's what she's
going to do whether or not you're buying
it or not
and i think that now our creative
process
is complicated it's not we're not just
writing we're doing a bunch of different
things
and also the larger the more success
that we've gotten and the bigger our
company has
become there's more people depending on
the stuff that we come up with working
than there were than there were
10 years ago right so now it's like okay
now we've got there's people's
livelihoods
are on the line right there's a company
there's employees
and so something working isn't just
about us and our like personal
creative fulfillment so it's a little
bit complicated but
the advantage we have with being able to
turn around and just be like well
there's gonna be another video on monday
there's going to be another podcast next
week there's going to be another
we're going to go right back to the
drawing board and start writing another
pilot for something or writing a movie
is that we we our home is pretty clear
we we always know where to come back to
and that's just coming back to the
creative process and just
turn something else out but specifically
good mythical morning and ear biscuits
being kind of like a creative
home base where it's properties that are
working
where we're reaching you
listening or watching you know it's
it's it's it's a it's quite a luxury
especially because we've been able to
structure our
professional lives to then spend a good
amount of time on speculative
stuff so i and i do want to get back to
that and reference the stuff we talked
about
last week everything that fizzled out
was rejected
or failed you know we
you weren't it it it's difficult for me
because i'm more of an you know i thrive
more in the execution phase and i don't
mean the killing but i mean carrying out
of the creative process then in the
ideation and
the writing of it um which is
a point that you thrive in so i'm
actually curious
how you interact with you know
a premature rejection it's like we we
write
we write a pitch we write five pitches
on a page like we read last week and
then
you know maybe none of them nobody's
excited about it so then we
say oh crap we'll just we'll just put
that in the google drive and read it on
your biscuits
years later and laugh about it but in
the moment it's like i gotta start over
already starting over and i'm sitting on
my hands like oh
okay gotta start over you know or
we are writing we decided to go write a
pilot and spend that amount of time
to invest in that knowing that
because it's a foray into traditional
entertainment
it's skipping tracks for us and we have
this
you know it's something we really want
we want
to uh we want to we want to
stretch our arms and build our muscles
creatively
and take some swings in other places
just just to just to get those type of
things
out into the world just to make that
type of stuff to have that challenge
and that experience and that reward
but we know that
we're not as special in fact what we
discover
is that i guess in in most people's
ideas and these gatekeepers
like we're not like the things that make
us special
or at least the popularity the and the
the momentum that we have excuse me and
the success that we have
not an asset it just doesn't seem it
might it gets us in the room
but it doesn't necessarily get things
made and
i would go as far as to say it's not an
asset it's a it's a liability
yeah i mean you you we at least start to
question that because it's like
okay we can get in the room but is it
okay are we are our ideas
and what we've written and what we our
pitches
is it are they not good enough well
there's other reasons out that don't
have anything to do with who we are
and like our ability and talent as
artists
but it is a part of it so it's like you
start you can get in your own head about
that type of stuff
um because you pitch in the room
and they're like there's there's a
million reasons to say no
and there seems to only be a few reasons
to say yes and then even a yes to a
pilot
is some it's an unknown length process
to then in an it's a crap
shoot that something ever gets made so
it's like
it's it's setting us up for a beating
and we've been so even though we're so
successful we focus on this
what we want to go after and we do have
this experience of taking
a beating you know so what
so how do we deal with that
and because because we keep signing up
for it
and it's re it's more frustrating for us
because we know the experience of
making something and have it and people
seeing it
and people liking it you know and
or if they don't it's a soft place to
fall we're so
we're spoiled right but we're but we're
trying to switch tracks and do something
different
i mean i'll
so i'll let you respond to that and then
i'll talk about
how
like i've tried to adjust my approach
mentally
to this entire process i mean i think
i'm thinking a lot of things
um you know
i definitely uh
there is a part of me that i've always
kind of had this belief that's probably
that's not a realistic belief
that we can do anything right
that it's kind of like you can date
anybody yeah we can if you set your
mind to something we can figure this out
we can we can write a book we can we can
write a movie
we can make music we can you know
and so we have done a lot of those
things because
there's just this persistent belief
that we can do it because i'm always
like well somebody
somebody figured it out you know and the
funny thing is is that
in big magic she she kind of talks one
of the things i always think that
when i'm writing for for instance
and i'm learning a lot while i'm writing
and i and especially if we have the
privilege of working with someone who's
more experienced
like we did on a recent thing that we
developed that's still kind of
maybe gonna be something but probably
not
you know is
my lack of experience and education in
the creative arts
becomes frustrating to me right now
meaning that i went to engineering
school right i didn't i i did i didn't
even pay attention in any of my
creative classes i i didn't i didn't
make the connection between
how there was an opportunity to like
pursue
vocationally entertainment until you
know
youtube came around and so
you start seeing that like okay well it
isn't easy to just
write something it's it doesn't just
come
naturally like there are sort of there
are some unspoken rules and there are
rules
that the people who are going to be
reading your scripts know they've been
educated they've read a lot of scripts
there's certain things that they're
looking for now i'm not you know
you can get way too formulaic in the
process but
one of the things that she talks about
in big magic is how
that creative education in academia is
kind of overrated right like the idea of
storytelling in general is something
that is
exists in our dna as a species and
this is this is who we are and then i
start questioning
well do i have anything important to say
like do we have something
that people will care about is this
original enough you know is this an
original idea
elizabeth says you know originality
is secondary to authenticity right
there's nothing
ultimately there's nothing original like
there's nothing new under the sun
you know solomon had that figured out
and so
you're going to do something that has
been done you're going to come up with a
melody that
is kind of already exist it's like
there's only so many combinations of
notes there's only so many
expressions of ideas there's only so
many stories you can tell but
only you as an individual
can tell your specific story in your
specific way
and so i that that's so this helps
counteract
this in an inferiority complex or
a fear of being exposed as
like uneducated or not or on talented
because everyone is faking it
you know when you think about it the
person that you're pitching to
is also faking it they're trying to
maintain their job
they they they they're they don't want
to get fired and they want to please the
person that they report to who wants to
please the person that they report to
who wants to be the man or whatever you
know so it's like
everyone is kind i'm not saying that you
know
technical creative writing education is
a bad thing i'm not i
think that would be great i wish i had
got had had it honestly right especially
given what i'm doing now
but when you kind of just are like
listen
this doesn't really matter
and also if i'm not enjoying every step
of the process
up to the point of rejection which the
good news is i am i enjoy writing i
i enjoy the process of creating a world
and exploring things and putting words
into into characters mouths and that
kind of thing
and every single time i do it i learn a
whole lot so i know the next time i do
it
it's going to be better and i'm probably
going to increase the chances will be
increased the next time that this will
come to light but you know what
if it doesn't it's just a lesson it's
just
an experience and
it's what was supposed to happen you
know even if that's not true
even if everything doesn't happen for a
reason living like everything happens
for a reason
is a healthy perspective i think for me
and this is something that i actually
started saying out loud
as we were entering into certain
processes
uh i'm thinking of two examples
one is um we were
we were doing a pitch and we had we had
teamed up with somebody who
if the pitch went as a television show
we would like they would be running the
they'd be the head writer and like show
runner
and we were we were pitching that
and then the other one is is is writing
the pilot that we collaborated with
you know a friend and mentor
yeah so with the first one i remember we
went
we were going into uh well it doesn't
matter which which network but
you know bona fide meeting big deal
uh by the way
we don't our livelihood is not connected
to
our pitches working for some for things
being bought from us
like we have this luxury of
not having this um
oh gosh i gotta you know this uh
i gotta put food on the table you know
we we gotta make this work
there's not a desperation there's not a
there's not a desperation
um but we want it so bad that it feels
the same
yeah at times and i do think that as you
were getting at it kind of short
that can short-circuit um your ability
to
to pitch and sell something i think when
it's like you're
you're gripping so tightly that you're
like shaking or you know
sometimes literally i remember we had
done it we had gone around town pitching
this thing and this was
this is the last person we were pitching
to
and remember we were sitting in the
waiting room with
uh the writer who we were we paired
ourselves with
and before we went back there i s you
remember i said to him i was like
well um you know what
if if if this doesn't this is our last
meeting if this doesn't go we may never
see you again
you know it's like we we were introduced
to him for this project we really hit it
off
i think you know i could see us being
really good friends
and collaborators and having an entire
creative future together or and that's
why that's one of the reasons we picked
the person
or this could be the last time that we
ever see each other
and like you know there was like this
kind of uncomfortable laughter
because we all knew it was true right
it's just not the type of thing that you
typically say unless you're linked and
you and you're a little nervous so
you're trying to figure out something to
talk about
uh and there's nothing like a good dose
of the truth to really shake you out of
being nervous and
that's that's exactly what happened that
is the la that was
a over a year ago and even without the
covet of it all
like we still would have never seen him
again i mean we might who knows if we'll
ever cross paths but it's just like
you know we we could be working together
for years or we could never see each
other
isn't that funny and the reason why i
said it is because i was trying to adopt
this philosophy that
like all of this stuff is so tenuous
like let's it at the least we can do is
be entertained by the process
because it may not be ever anything more
than this
like we go into this pitch we practiced
it
we we kind of know it backwards and
forwards
um let's have fun with it if all that
happens with this project
and it never goes past a pitch well i
want to have fond memories of this pitch
like i want to take the pressure off and
just convey that we believe in it
and lead the results to whatever
whatever power you want to leave the
results to
so that's the thing that i was trying to
do was just embrace the process
because the results are out of our
control
and all you yeah all we can do is we can
come up with an idea we can write a
story and we can have
a compelling pitch but it is so tenuous
because the reason that someone might
say no
could very easily be what they had for
lunch it could be a conversation that
they had with their spouse
right before the meeting and that can be
frustrating or it can be
fueled to let go of the things that that
you just have an illusion i think when
you actually think about it
and when you understand how tenuous it
is
for me it is helpful to be like you know
what
why would i place my value
my happiness in the hands of someone who
just had a bad lunch you know what i'm
saying
like what and so again it is frustrating
when you take the
but i feel like for me it's
step one is finding joy in the process
what you just said like and that is
everything from
the conceptualization and the writing to
going out and talking about it meeting
people doing the pitches like having fun
while we're doing it
and then the second thing is is and this
is not easy
i want to be very clear this isn't easy
for anybody it's definitely not easy for
me
somebody who built an identity on
you know impressing people
to take all the power
to to give the the the results
the x my expectations there's no power
in that i'm just
removing all my expectations
uh all together and trying to detach
myself from the outcome
if i can have if i can enjoy the process
and detach myself from the outcome
and again there's things that make that
easier for us given the fact that
it doesn't have to work like we can go
back we can keep doing what we're doing
it's we're going to be okay in the short
term financially
you know we're not depending on this
working in order to
yeah eat yeah uh so those are the
and again if that's your situation
again i know i'm i'm i'm biting a lot of
elizabeth gilbert's thoughts here but
i mean she kind of makes the point that
because
the process the arts are so tenuous and
because
people you're putting your livelihood
into the whims of another person who
holds the purse strings
she recommends don't quit your day job i
know that sounds
harsh but she's like she didn't
stop working her day job until
after she published eat pray love and it
started seeming like it was working
like she she was she she had all these
different jobs
and she was like um find find make
yourself
give yourself that creative time but the
moment that you begin to
attach yourself and attach your
self-worth and attach
your own livelihood to it
it becomes a it becomes a different
thing now we've got we've had the
privilege of
okay well the baseline creativity stuff
is working so we have this privilege of
being able to kind of do that
to put these things out into the world
and not have them have to work but yeah
and with the
with that second example of uh
you know co-writing a pilot was with
somebody with a lot more experience that
can give you know just being on
zoom calls and having that time was just
like you know this is just
you know the thing that i would remind
myself and just i would say out loud
at times to all of us on the zoom call
is i was like
you know like you said this may never
this may never be anything but
uh it's it's fun to think about
what it could be and it this is fun
right now
like this experience is fun like finding
like
taking that moment to pause and
recognize oh
we just got notes but the way he gives
notes is he he does
he records it all audio stream of
consciousness and then he just emails it
to you so like you've got this like
verbal processing of what we've
conceptualized
and what you've written and there's like
this detailed
analysis of it that like people would
pay
people would save up for years to get
that type of feedback on something
they've written
from from someone of you know this level
of experience
and just saying okay
i might be the notes might eviscerate
and i actually and they didn't but even
if they did it's like
wow what a what a cool process it's like
going to
signing up for your driving course and
then you get to the parking lot and mr
miyagi gets in the car with you with a
glass of wine
it's like oh god this is this is
freaking cool
i need to go home and watch karate kid
now and i think i would really ex
really appreciate this yeah you know
what i'm saying and it's tough to do
that it's tough to
enjoy the process because i think there
is a
there's this romantic notion of the of
the starving artist
and the desperate artist and the
tortured
artist you know literally you know
somebody like van gogh cutting off his
own ear you know
like you have this this is cultural
entity which is you've got
to drag yourself through
a torturous experience in in order to
come out on the other side in success
and it's like well first of all the
success on the other side
may be just as disorienting as the
failure and the struggle
you are who you are and your baseline
happiness is kind of pre-tuned
you know what i'm saying um so
it's very difficult for me because i've
cause i'll because i always have thought
that
yeah this is supposed to be this like
i'm this is supposed to be a grind and
you're really supposed to just like
throw yourself in this and be able to
look back and be like oh man we worked
so hard on that and then it became a
thing but it's just like
i don't know if it's gonna become a
thing can i just learn to enjoy
these the steps i mean who knows if one
of these things becomes a reality
it'll be fun it'll be awesome but it'll
also complicate our lives in a certain
way right
like okay we do a hundred different
things already
let's throw 101 in there and this one
will be
making a television show making a movie
i'm not saying we won't find a way to
make it happen
but you know what it'll be stressful
it'll be
it'll be a complicating factor in things
yeah so it's not always
like the success or something happening
is going to be some
incredible thing that is going to change
change your life you know
um yeah so i i think
ultimately for me it's just
a constant battle to detach myself from
the
from the outcome and also to when the
outcome is failure which is
most often with especially with the
stuff that we're talking it's in fact
only almost exclusively failure and
rejection with the ideas that we've
talked about before
um seeing that there's probably
ultimately more long-term value in those
in
those rejections and failures than there
would be in one of them working out
and i think my chief struggle is
something
that will make more sense in light of
our enneagram conversations over the
next couple of weeks because my struggle
is
when things are so speculative
and you they're not actually like nuts
and bolts of doing and
and like perfecting
like executing and perfecting like the
next parts of the creative process like
if
if a project never gets off the ground
and that keeps happening and happening i
get very
uh dejected i feel like i'm sitting on
my hands you know because i'm not
the writer and you know i'm not as much
of the
idea from nothing comes an idea it's
more of like
yes i i'm i get on board
with those things and then let's go for
it right
you know so there's a different type of
struggle for me uh
in this kind of like to stay engaged
when it's you know our hands have been
tied with kovid
and but also so much is speculative
and now we're you know we've actually
got people whose full-time job is to
as a development person i can i don't
think i could ever be a development
person
because now that we're working closely
with
mallory and taylor who are like working
for us full-time to
take our ideas develop other ideas bring
projects in and like get
traditional things off the ground it's
like it's very hard for me to
uh to remain engaged because it's just
so speculative i can just be like
this isn't this is never going to happen
i'm never going to be able to engage
what i feel like
my gifts and my passions are because
we're just
we're we're we're just meandering around
the starting line and then no one may
ever fire the gun
to run you know it's like call me when
it's time to run you know
and so it's been it that's
that's a that's what's been difficult
for me and it's not even
so then i start to anticipate the
rejection
and just disengage i think to protect
myself
from the dejection of
of never getting to the part that's
where i feel like like i i thrive and i
can find my flow
right and maybe that'll come up more or
you can just kind of take what i just
said and map it onto being
an enneagram one next week so and i
think that's one of the reasons that we
end up
uh you know we've got something planned
we have a cree we have a creative
exercise yeah we do that we have planned
for the fall that
is we have complete control over it and
it is going to happen
we're going to make it yeah and and i
and i think
for me that was a reaction to what
you're
what you're talking about yeah sure i
may be engaged in like the writing
process but
when you've for years you've been able
to
put things out there whether it was a
music video or a sketch
with something that's a that's it coming
from a different place creatively then
obviously good mythical morning is its
own entity but it but
good mythical morning has become as
we've established it's been
it's become an environment that we place
ourselves into
and we're just kind of operating off the
cuff and as
ourselves and kind of being ourselves
and our friendship is on display and
that kind of thing it's a different kind
of entertainment than something that's
because the conceptual stages are
happening with the writing team and
producers and on purpose it's like we're
not trying to like throw ourselves back
into gmm creatively
we're throwing ourselves into other
places creatively and
but then after a while you're like well
okay we got to get something we used to
at least have like a
sketch or a music video or something
like that that would get out there and
it's a different process of
throwing that out into the world and
having people react to it
so i think that our reaction to
feeling a little bit restricted
in that way is to say well let's let's
put something out there
you know and so that i i don't want to
build it up too much
because it's not going to be anything
that they're going to
that they can predict yeah and so if
they
agree with that so don't if you think
anything that you could predict
and would then you would get excited
about don't do it because it's not that
type of thing right
but we're excited about it and uh i'm
gonna leave it at that
i'm gonna make a recommendation you know
you had your creative book
which uh uh i'm actually listening to it
i'm i'm not that far into it but i
really appreciated
early on she talks about fear being
a um a barrier to
to creativity um i'd i've
i was going in a a record shop
and i found i knew this existed and then
i i'd forgotten and then i remembered so
i picked it up
questlove wrote a creative book
called creative quest a creativity book
is what i meant to say
i'm not all the way through this thing i
skipped to the last chapter so that
it could inform our success and failure
is one of the last chapters
and so um i'm a big fan of quest love
you know honored to have met him
in the in the halls of actually we met
him
we didn't meet him on the halls of the
tonight show we met him
during the we just met him during the
show i mean quest love played drums
for us to rap in that crazy our
eighth grade quest love was awesome
eighth grade talent show
halloween fall festival thing so he hazy
so uh creative quest fun book
uh it talks about
it you know it's his relationship with
creativity and
the thing that got me uh was his
his opening line uh decades into my
career with many albums and songs under
my belt i still
don't know if i am truly creative most
days i spend more time
absorbing the creative work around me
than actually creating myself
at times i feel like i'm a way better
student than i am a teacher
or a maker and
that really resonated with me i think a
lot of
you know what i said just a few seconds
ago about um
you know that's a testimony to to our
teamwork
that we will talk about with the
enneagram that was like okay a guy who
is undeniably creative has this
like this doubt in his mind if he would
call himself that because of the way
that he engages
with uh the creative world
is is uh is different so
if you're into quest love if that
resonates with you
creative quest is my recommendation
tell us about your experience with
creativity
failure rejection hashtag your biscuit
biscuits that's what we're calling it
now air biscuits this has been a loss
yeah uh and we love to talk about how
much we suck
join us join us next week as we finally
get into the enneagram
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]